The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JULIAN SHUN: All right.
So we've talked a little
bit about caching before,
but today we're going to talk in
much more detail about caching
and how to design
cache-efficient algorithms.
So first, let's look
at the caching hardware
on modern machines today.
So here's what the
cache hierarchy looks
like for a multicore chip.
We have a whole
bunch of processors.
They all have their
own private L1 caches
for both the data, as
well as the instruction.
They also have a
private L2 cache.
And then they share a last
level cache, or L3 cache,
which is also called LLC.
They're all connected
to a memory controller
that can access DRAM.
And then, oftentimes,
you'll have multiple chips
on the same server,
and these chips
would be connected
through a network.
So here we have a bunch
of multicore chips
that are connected together.
So we can see that there are
different levels of memory
here.
And the sizes of each one
of these levels of memory
is different.
So the sizes tend to
go up as you move up
the memory hierarchy.
The L1 caches tend to
be about 32 kilobytes.
In fact, these are the
specifications for the machines
that you're using in this class.
So 32 kilobytes for
both the L1 data cache
and the L1 instruction cache.
256 kilobytes for the L2 cache.
so the L2 cache tends to
be about 8 to 10 times
larger than the L1 cache.
And then the last level cache,
the size is 30 megabytes.
So this is typically on the
order of tens of megabytes.
And then DRAM is on
the order of gigabytes.
So here we have
128 gigabyte DRAM.
And nowadays, you can
actually get machines
that have terabytes of DRAM.
So the associativity tends
to go up as you move up
the cache hierarchy.
And I'll talk more
about associativity
on the next couple of slides.
The time to access the
memory also tends to go up.
So the latency tends
to go up as you move up
the memory hierarchy.
So the L1 caches are
the quickest to access,
about two nanoseconds,
just rough numbers.
The L2 cache is a
little bit slower--
so say four nanoseconds.
Last level cache,
maybe six nanoseconds.
And then when you
have to go to DRAM,
it's about an order of magnitude
slower-- so 50 nanoseconds
in this example.
And the reason why the memory
is further down in the cache
hierarchy are faster
is because they're
using more expensive materials
to manufacture these things.
But since they tend to be more
expensive, we can't fit as much
of that on the machines.
So that's why the faster
memories are smaller
than the slower memories.
But if we're able to take
advantage of locality
in our programs, then we can
make use of the fast memory
as much as possible.
And we'll talk about ways to
do that in this lecture today.
There's also the latency
across the network, which
tends to be cheaper than
going to main memory
but slower than doing a
last level cache access.
And there's a lot
of work in trying
to get the cache coherence
protocols right, as we
mentioned before.
So since these processors
all have private caches,
we need to make
sure that they all
see a consistent
view of memory when
they're trying to
access the same memory
addresses in parallel.
So we talked about the
MSI cache protocol before.
And there are many other
protocols out there,
and you can read more
about these things online.
But these are very
hard to get right,
and there's a lot of
verification involved
in trying to prove that the
cache coherence protocols are
correct.
So any questions so far?
OK.
So let's talk about the
associativity of a cache.
So here I'm showing you a
fully associative cache.
And in a fully
associative cache,
a cache block can reside
anywhere in the cache.
And a basic unit of movement
here is a cache block.
In this example, the cache
block size is 4 bytes,
but on the machines that
we're using for this class,
the cache block
size is 64 bytes.
But for this example, I'm going
to use a four byte cache line.
So each row here corresponds
to one cache line.
And a fully associative cache
means that each line here
can go anywhere in the cache.
And then here
we're also assuming
a cache size that has 32 bytes.
So, in total, it can
store eight cache line
since the cache line is 4 bytes.
So to find a block in a
fully associative cache,
you have to actually
search the entire cache,
because a cache line can
appear anywhere in the cache.
And there's a tag associated
with each of these cache lines
here that basically
specify which
of the memory addresses
in virtual memory space
it corresponds to.
So for the fully
associative cache,
we're actually going to use
most of the bits of that address
as a tag.
We don't actually need
the two lower order
bits, because the
things are being
moved at the granularity
of cache lines, which
are four bytes.
So the two lower order bits are
always going to be the same,
but we're just going to
use the rest of the bits
to store the tag.
So if our address
space is 64 bits,
then we're going to use 62 bits
to store the tag in a fully
associative caching scheme.
And when a cache
becomes full, a block
has to be evicted to make
room for a new block.
And there are various
ways that you can
decide how to evict a block.
So this is known as
the replacement policy.
One common replacement policy
is LRU Least Recently Used.
So you basically kick
the thing out that
has been used the
farthest in the past.
The other schemes, such
as second chance and clock
replacement, we're
not going to talk
too much about the different
replacement schemes today.
But you can feel free to read
about these things online.
So what's a disadvantage
of this scheme?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: It's slow.
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah.
Why is it slow?
AUDIENCE: Because you have to
go all the way [INAUDIBLE]..
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah.
So the disadvantage
is that searching
for a cache line in the cache
can be pretty slow, because you
have to search entire
cache in the worst case,
since a cache block can
reside anywhere in the cache.
So even though the search can
go on in parallel and hardware
is still expensive in terms
of power and performance
to have to search most
of the cache every time.
So let's look at
another extreme.
This is a direct mapped cache.
So in a direct mapped
cache, each cache block
can only go in one
place in the cache.
So I've color-coded
these cache blocks here.
So the red blocks can only go
in the first row of this cache,
the orange ones can only go
in the second row, and so on.
And the position which a
cache block can go into
is known as that
cache blocks set.
So the set determines
the location
in the cache for each
particular block.
So let's look at how the virtual
memory address is divided up
into and which of
the bits we're going
to use to figure out
where a cache block should
go in the cache.
So we have the offset,
we have the set,
and then the tag fields.
The offset just tells
us which position
we want to access
within a cache block.
So since a cache
block has B bytes,
we only need log base 2
of B bits as the offset.
And the reason why
we have to offset
is because we're not
always accessing something
at the beginning
of a cache block.
We might want to access
something in the middle.
And that's why we
need the offset
to specify where in the cache
block we want to access.
Then there's a set field.
And the set field is going
to determine which position
in the cache that cache
block can go into.
So there are eight possible
positions for each cache block.
And therefore, we only
need log base 2 of 8 bits--
so three bits for the
set in this example.
And more generally, it's going
to be log base 2 of M over B.
And here, M over B is 8.
And then, finally, we're
going to use the remaining
bits as a tag.
So w minus log base 2
of M bits for the tag.
And that gets stored along with
the cache block in the cache.
And that's going to
uniquely identify
which of the memory blocks
the cache block corresponds to
in virtual memory.
And you can verify that the
sum of all these quantities
here sums to w bits.
So in total, we have
a w bit address space.
And the sum of those
three things is w.
So what's the advantage and
disadvantage of this scheme?
So first, what's a good thing
about this scheme compared
to the previous
scheme that we saw?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Faster.
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah.
It's fast because you only
have to check one place.
Because each cache
block can only
go in one place in a cache,
and that's only place
you have to check when
you try to do a lookup.
If the cache block is
there, then you find it.
If it's not, then you know
it's not in the cache.
What's the downside
to this scheme?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You only end
up putting the red ones
into the cache and you have
mostly every [INAUDIBLE],, which
is totally [INAUDIBLE].
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah.
So good answer.
So the downside is that you
might, for example, just
be accessing the
red cache blocks
and then not accessing any
of the other cache blocks.
They'll all get mapped to the
same location in the cache,
and then they'll keep
evicting each other,
even though there's a lot
of empty space in the cache.
And this is known
as a conflict miss.
And these can be very
bad for performance
and very hard to debug.
So that's one downside
of a direct map
cache is that you can get these
conflict misses where you have
to evict things from the
cache even though there's
empty space in the cache.
So as we said, finding
a block is very fast.
Only a single location in
the cache has to be searched.
But you might
suffer from conflict
misses if you keep axing
things in the same set
repeatedly without accessing
the things in the other sets.
So any questions?
OK.
So these are sort of the two
extremes for cache design.
There's actually
a hybrid solution
called set associative cache.
And in a set associative
cache, you still sets,
but each of the sets contains
more than one line now.
So all the red blocks
still map to the red set,
but there's actually
two possible locations
for the red blocks now.
So in this case, this is known
as a two-way associate of cache
since there are two possible
locations inside each set.
And again, a cache block's set
determines k possible cache
locations for that block.
So within a set it's
fully associative,
but each block can only
go in one of the sets.
So let's look again
at how the bits are
divided into in the address.
So we still have the tag
set and offset fields.
The offset field is
still a log base 2 of b.
The set field is going to take
log base 2 of M over kB bits.
So the number of sets
we have is M over kB.
So we need log base
2 of that number
to represent the set of a block.
And then, finally, we use
the remaining bits as a tag,
so it's going to be w minus
log base 2 of M over k.
And now, to find a
block in the cache,
only k locations of it's
set must be searched.
So you basically find which
set the cache block maps too,
and then you check
all k locations
within that set to see if
that cached block is there.
And whenever you
want to whenever
you try to put something in the
cache because it's not there,
you have to evict something.
And you evict something from
the same set as the block
that you're placing
into the cache.
So for this example, I showed
a two-way associative cache.
But in practice, the
associated is usually bigger
say eight-way, 16-way,
or sometimes 20-way.
And as you keep increasing
the associativity,
it's going to look more and more
like a fully associative cache.
And if you have a one
way associative cache,
then there's just
a direct map cache.
So this is a sort of a hybrid in
between-- a fully mapped cache
and a fully associative
cache in a direct map cache.
So any questions on set
associative caches ?
OK.
So let's go over a taxonomy
of different types of cache
misses that you can incur.
So the first type of cache
miss is called a cold miss.
And this is the
cache miss that you
have to incur the first time
you access a cache block.
And if you need to access
this piece of data,
there's no way to get around
getting a cold miss for this.
Because your cache starts
out not having this block,
and the first time
you access it,
you have to bring it into cache.
Then there are capacity misses.
So capacity misses
are cache misses
You get because
the cache is full
and it can't fit all
of the cache blocks
that you want to access.
So you get a capacity miss
when the previous cache
copy would have been
evicted even with a fully
associative scheme.
So even if all of the possible
locations in your cache
could be used for a
particular cache line,
that cache line still has to
be evicted because there's not
enough space.
So that's what's
called a capacity miss.
And you can deal
with capacity misses
by introducing more locality
into your code, both spatial
and temporal locality.
And we'll look at ways
to reduce the capacity
misses of algorithms
later on in this lecture.
Then there are conflict misses.
And conflict misses happen
in set associate of caches
when you have too many blocks
from the same set wanting
to go into the cache.
And some of these
have to be evicted,
because the set can't
fit all of the blocks.
And these blocks
wouldn't have been
evicted if you had a fully
associative scheme, so these
are what's called
conflict misses.
For example, if you
have 16 things in a set
and you keep accessing 17 things
that all belong in the set,
something's going
to get kicked out
every time you want
to access something.
And these cache
evictions might not
have happened if you had
a fully associative cache.
And then, finally,
they're sharing misses.
So sharing misses only
happened in a parallel context.
And we talked a little
bit about true sharing
a false sharing misses
in prior lectures.
So let's just
review this briefly.
So a sharing miss can happen
if multiple processors are
accessing the same cache
line and at least one of them
is writing to that cache line.
If all of the
processors are just
reading from the cache line,
then the cache [INAUDIBLE]
protocol knows how to make
it work so that you don't get
misses.
They can all access the same
cache line at the same time
if nobody's modifying it.
But if at least one
processor is modifying it,
you could get either
true sharing misses
or false sharing misses.
So a true sharing miss is
when two processors are
accessing the same data
on the same cache line.
And as you recall from
a previous lecture,
if one of the two processors
is writing to this cache
line, whenever it
does a write it
needs to acquire the cache
line in exclusive mode
and then invalidate that cache
line and all other caches.
So then when one
another processor
tries to access the
same memory location,
it has to bring it back
into its own cache,
and then you get a
cache miss there.
A false sharing this
happens if two processes
are accessing different data
that just happened to reside
on the same cache line.
Because the basic
unit of movement
is a cache line in
the architecture.
So even if you're
asking different things,
if they are on the
same cache line,
you're still going to
get a sharing miss.
And false sharing is
pretty hard to deal with,
because, in general,
you don't know what data
gets placed on what cache line.
There are certain
heuristics you can use.
For example, if you're
mallocing a big memory region,
you know that that memory
region is contiguous,
so you can space your
access is far enough apart
by different processors so
they don't touch the same cache
line.
But if you're just declaring
local variables on the stack,
you don't know
where the compiler
is going to decide to
place these variables
in the virtual
memory address space.
So these are four
different types of cache
misses that you
should know about.
And there's many
models out there
for analyzing the cache
performance of algorithms.
And some of the models ignore
some of these different types
of cache misses.
So just be aware of this when
you're looking at algorithm
analysis, because
not all of the models
will capture all of these
different types of cache
misses.
So let's look at a bad
case for conflict misses.
So here I want to access a
submatrix within a larger
matrix.
And recall that matrices are
stored in row-major order.
And let's say our matrix is
4,096 columns by 4,096 rows
and it still stores doubles.
So therefore, each
row here is going
to contain 2 to the 15th
bytes, because 4,096
is t2 to the 12th,
and we have doubles,
which takes eight bytes.
So 2 to the 12 times to the
3rd, which is 2 to the 15th.
We're going to assume the word
width is 64, which is standard.
We're going to assume that
we have a cache size of 32k.
And the cache block size is
64, which, again, is standard.
And let's say we have a
four-way associative cache.
So let's look at how the
bits are divided into.
So again we have
this offset, which
takes log base 2 of B bits.
So how many bits do we have
for the offset in this example?
Right.
So we have 6 bits.
So it's just log base 2 of 64.
What about for the set?
How many bits do
we have for that?
7.
Who said 7?
Yeah.
So it is 7.
So M is 32k, which
is 2 to the 15th.
And then k is 2 to
the 2, b is 2 6.
So it's 2 to the 15th divided by
2 the 8th, which is to the 7th.
And log base 2 of that is 7.
And finally, what
about the tag field?
AUDIENCE: 51.
JULIAN SHUN: 51.
Why is that?
AUDIENCE: 64 minus 13.
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah.
So it's just 64 minus
7 minus 6, which is 51.
OK.
So let's say that we want
to access a submatrix
within this larger matrix.
Let's say we want to acts
as a 32 by 32 submatrix.
And THIS is pretty common
in matrix algorithms, where
you want to access submatrices,
especially in divide
and conquer algorithms.
And let's say we want to access
a column of this submatrix A.
So the addresses of the elements
that we're going to access
are as follows--
so let's say the first
element in the column
is stored at address x.
Then the second
element in the column
is going to be stored at
address x plus 2 to the 15th,
because each row has
2 to the 15th bytes,
and we're skipping
over an entire row
here to get to the element in
the next row of the sub matrix.
So we're going to
add 2 to the 15th.
And then to get
the third element,
we're going to add 2
times 2 to the 15th.
And so on, until we get
to the last element,
which is x plus 31
times 2 to the 15th.
So which fields
of the address are
changing as we go through
one column of this submatrix?
AUDIENCE: You're just adding
multiple [INAUDIBLE] tag
the [INAUDIBLE].
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah.
So it's just going to be
the tag that's changing.
The set and the offset are going
to stay the same, because we're
just using the lower 13 bits
to store the set and a tag.
And therefore, when we
increment by 2 to the 15th,
we're not going to touch
the set and the offset.
So all of these addresses
fall into the same set.
And this is a problem,
because our cache
is only four-way associative.
So we can only fit four
cache lines in each set.
And here, we're accessing
31 of these things.
So by the time we get
to the next column of A,
all the things that we access
in the current column of A
are going to be evicted
from cache already.
And this is known
as a conflict miss,
because if you had a
fully associative cache
this might not have happened,
because you could actually
use any location in the cache
to store these cache blocks.
So does anybody have
any questions on why
we get conflict misses here?
So anybody have any
ideas on how to fix this?
So what can I do to
make it so that I'm not
incrementing by exactly
2 to the 15th every time?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So pad the matrix?
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah.
So one solution is
to pad the matrix.
You can add some
constant amount of space
to the end of the matrix.
So each row is going
to be longer than 2
to the 15th bytes.
So maybe you add some
small constant like 17.
So add 17 bytes to
the end of each row.
And now, when you access a
column of this submatrix,
you're not just incrementing
by 2 to the 15th,
you're also adding
some small integer.
And that's going to cause
the set and the offset fields
to change as well,
and you're not
going to get as many
conflict misses.
So that's one way to
solve the problem.
It turns out that if you're
doing a matrix multiplication
algorithm, that's a
cubic work algorithm,
and you can basically
afford to copy the submatrix
into a temporary
32 by 32 matrix,
do all the operations
on the temporary matrix,
and then copy it back out
to the original matrix.
The copying only
takes quadratic work
to do across the
whole algorithm.
And since the whole
algorithm takes cubic work,
the quadratic work is
a lower order term.
So you can use temporary
space to make sure that you
don't get conflict misses.
Any questions?
So this was conflict misses.
So conflict misses
are important.
But usually, we're going
to be first concerned
about getting good spatial
and temporal locality,
because those are
usually the higher order
factors in the
performance of a program.
And once we get good spatial
and temporal locality
in our program,
we can then start
worrying about conflict
misses, for example,
by using temporary space
or padding our data
by some small constants
so that we don't
have as if any conflict misses.
So now, I want to
talk about a model
that we can use to
analyze the cache
performance of algorithms.
And this is called
the ideal-cache model.
So in this model, we have a
two-level cache hierarchy.
So we have the cache
and then main memory.
The cache size is of size
M, and the cache line size
is of B bytes.
And therefore, we can fit M over
V cache lines inside our cache.
This model assumes that the
cache is fully associative,
so any cache block can
go anywhere in the cache.
And it also assumes an optimal
omniscient replacement policy.
So this means that where
we want to evict a cache
block from the
cache, we're going
to pick the thing to
evict that gives us
the best performance overall.
It gives us the
lowest number of cache
misses throughout
our entire algorithm.
So we're assuming that we know
the sequence of memory requests
throughout the entire algorithm.
And that's why it's called the
omniscient mission replacement
policy.
And if something is in cache,
you can operate on it for free.
And if something
is in main memory,
you have to bring it
into cache and then
you incur a cache miss.
So two performance measures
that we care about--
first, we care about
the ordinary work,
which is just the ordinary
running time of a program.
So this is the
same as before when
we were analyzing algorithms.
It's just a total
number of operations
that the program does.
And the number of
cache misses is
going to be the
number of lines we
have to transfer between the
main memory and the cache.
So the number of
cache misses just
counts a number of
cache transfers,
whereas as the work counts
all the operations that you
have to do in the algorithm.
So ideally, we would
like to come up
with algorithms that have a
low number of cache misses
without increasing the work
from the traditional standard
algorithm.
Sometimes we can do that,
sometimes we can't do that.
And then there's a
trade-off between the work
and the number of cache misses.
And it's a trade-off
that you have
to decide whether it's
worthwhile as a performance
engineer.
Today, we're going to
look at an algorithm
where you can't actually
reduce the number of cache
misses without
increasing the work.
So you basically get
the best of both worlds.
So any questions on
this ideal cache model?
So this model is just used
for analyzing algorithms.
You can't actually buy one
of these caches at the store.
So this is a very ideal
cache, and they don't exist.
But it turns out that this
optimal omniscient replacement
policy has nice
theoretical properties.
And this is a very important
lemma that was proved in 1985.
It's called the LRU lemma.
It was proved by
Slater and Tarjan.
And the lemma says, suppose
that an algorithm incurs
Q cache misses on an ideal
cache of size M. Then,
on a fully associative cache
of size 2M, that uses the LRU,
or Least Recently Used
replacement policy,
it incurs at most
2Q cache misses.
So what this says is if I
can show the number of cache
misses for an algorithm
on the ideal cache,
then if I take a fully
associative cache that's twice
the size and use the
LRU replacement policy,
which is a pretty
practical policy,
then the algorithm
is going to incur,
at most, twice the
number of cache misses.
And the implication
of this lemma
is that for asymptotic
analyses, you
can assume either the optimal
replacement policy or the LRU
replacement policy
as convenient.
Because the number
of cache misses
is just going to be within a
constant factor of each other.
So this is a very
important lemma.
It says that this
basically makes
it much easier for us to analyze
our cache misses in algorithms.
And here's a software
engineering principle
that I want to point out.
So first, when you're trying
to get good performance,
you should come up with a
theoretically good algorithm
that has good balance on the
work and the cache complexity.
And then after you come up
with an algorithm that's
theoretically good, then
you start engineering
for detailed performance.
You start worrying about the
details such as real world
caches not being fully
associative, and, for example,
loads and stores having
different costs with respect
to bandwidth and latency.
But coming up with a
theoretically good algorithm
is the first order bit to
getting good performance.
Questions?
So let's start analyzing
the number of cache
misses in a program.
So here's a lemma.
So the lemma says, suppose that
a program reads a set of r data
segments, where the i-th segment
consists of s sub i bytes.
And suppose that the sum of
the sizes of all the segments
is equal to N. And we're going
to assume that N is less than M
over 3.
So the sum of the
size of the segments
is less than the cache
size divided by 3.
We're also going to
assume that N over r
is greater than or
equal to B. So recall
that r is the number of
data segments we have,
and N is the total
size of the segment.
So what does N over
r mean, semantically?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Average [INAUDIBLE].
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah.
So N over r is the just the
average size of a segment.
And here we're saying that
the average size of a segment
is at least B-- so at least
the size of a cache line.
So if these two assumptions
hold, then all of the segments
are going to fit into cache,
and the number of cache
misses to read them all is,
at most, 3 times N over B.
So if you had just a
single array of size N,
then the number of
cache misses you
would need to read
that array into cache
is going to be N
over B. And this
is saying that, even
if our data is divided
into a bunch of segments, as
long as the average length
of the segments is large enough,
then the number of cache misses
is just a constant factor worse
than reading a single array.
So let's try to prove
this cache miss lemma.
So here's a proof so.
A single segment,
s sub i is going
to incur at most s sub i
over B plus 2 cache misses.
So does anyone want to tell me
where the s sub i over B plus 2
comes from?
So let's say this is a
segment that we're analyzing,
and this is how it's
aligned in virtual memory.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: How many blocks
it could overlap worst case.
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah.
So s sub i over B plus 2 is
the number of blocks that could
overlap within the worst case.
So you need s sub i
over B cache misses just
to load those s sub i bytes.
But then the beginning and
the end of that segment
might not be perfectly aligned
with a cache line boundary.
And therefore, you could
waste, at most, one block
on each side of the segment.
So that's where the
plus 2 comes from.
So to get the total
number of cache
misses, we just have to sum this
quantity from i equals 1 to r.
So if I sum s sub i over
B from i equals 1 to r,
I just get N over
B, by definition.
And then I sum 2
from i equals 1 to r.
So that just gives me 2r.
Now, I'm going to multiply
the top and the bottom
with the second term by
B. So 2r B over B now.
And then that's less
than or equal to N over B
plus 2N over B. So where did
I get this inequality here?
Why do I know that 2r B is
less than or equal to 2N?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: You know that the N
is greater than or equal to B r.
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah.
So you know that N is
greater than or equal to B
r by this assumption up here.
So therefore, r B is
less than or equal to N.
And then, N B plus 2 N
B just sums up to 3 N B.
So in the worst case, we're
going to incur 3N over B cache
misses.
So any questions on
this cache miss lemma?
So the Important thing to
remember here is that if you
have a whole bunch of data
segments and the average length
of your segments
is large enough--
bigger than a cache block size--
then you can access all
of these segments just
like a single array.
It only increases
the number of cache
misses by a constant factor.
And if you're doing an
asymptotic analysis,
then it doesn't matter.
So we're going to be using
this cache miss lemma later
on when we analyze algorithms.
So another assumption
that we're going to need
is called the tall
cache assumption.
And the tall cache
assumption basically
says that the cache is
taller than it is wide.
So it says that B
squared is less than c M
for some sufficiently
small constant c less than
or equal to 1.
So in other words, it says
that the number of cache lines
M over B you have is
going to be bigger than B.
And this tall cache
assumption is usually
satisfied in practice.
So here are the cache
line sizes and the cache
sizes on the machines
that we're using.
So cache line size is 64
bytes, and the L1 cache size
is 32 kilobytes.
So 64 bytes squared,
that's 2 to the 12th.
And 32 kilobytes is
2 to the 15th bytes.
So 2 to the 12th is
less than 2 to the 15th,
so it satisfies the
tall cache assumption.
And as we go up the
memory hierarchy,
the cache size increases,
but the cache line length
stays the same.
So the cache has
become even taller
as we move up the
memory hierarchy.
So let's see why this
tall cache assumption is
going to be useful.
To see that, we're
going to look at what's
wrong with a short cache.
So in a short cache, our lines
are going to be very wide,
and they're wider than
the number of lines
that we can have in our cache.
And let's say we're
working with an m
by n submatrix sorted
in row-major order.
If you have a short cache,
then even if n squared
is less than c M,
meaning that you
can fit all the bytes of
the submatrix in cache,
you might still not be able
to fit it into a short cache.
And this picture sort
of illustrates this.
So we have m rows here.
But we can only fit M over
B of the rows in the cache,
because the cache
lines are so long,
and we're actually
wasting a lot of space
on each of the cache lines.
We're only using a very small
fraction of each cache line
to store the row
of this submatrix.
If this were the
entire matrix, then
it would actually be OK,
because consecutive rows
are going to be placed together
consecutively in memory.
But if this is a
submatrix, then we
can't be guaranteed that the
next row is going to be placed
right after the current row.
And oftentimes, we have
to deal with submatrices
when we're doing recursive
matrix algorithms.
So this is what's wrong
with short caches.
And that's why we want us assume
the tall cache assumption.
And we can assume that,
because it's usually
satisfied in practice.
The TLB be actually
tends to be short.
It only has a couple of
entries, so it might not satisfy
the tall cache assumption.
But all of the other caches
will satisfy this assumption.
Any questions?
OK.
So here's another lemma
that's going to be useful.
This is called the
submatrix caching llama.
So suppose that we
have an n by m matrix,
and it's read into
a tall cache that
satisfies B squared less than c
M for some constant c less than
or equal to 1.
And suppose that n squared
is less than M over 3,
but it's greater than
or equal to c M. Then
A is going to fit into cache,
and the number of cache
misses required to read all
of A's elements into cache is,
at most, 3n squared over B.
So let's see why this is true.
So we're going to
let big N denote
the total number of bytes
that we need to access.
So big N is going to
be equal to n squared.
And we're going to use the
cache miss lemma, which
says that if the average
length of our segments
is large enough, then we
can read all of the segments
in just like it were a
single contiguous array.
So the lengths of our segments
here are going to be little n.
So r is going to be a little n.
And also, the number of segments
is going to be little n.
And the segment
length is also going
to be little n, since we're
working with a square submatrix
here.
And then we also have the
cache block size B is less than
or equal to n.
And that's equal
to big N over r.
And where do we get this
property that B is less than
or equal to n?
So I made some
assumptions up here,
where I can use to infer that
B is less than or equal to n.
Does anybody see where?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So B squared
is less than c M,
and c M is [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah.
So I know that B
squared is less than c
M. C M is less than
or equal to n squared.
So therefore, B squared
is less than n squared,
and B is less than n.
So now, I also have
that N is less than M
over 3, just by assumption.
And therefore, I can use
the cache miss lemma.
So the cache miss lemma
tells me that I only
need a total of 3n
squared over B cache
misses to read this
whole thing in.
Any questions on the
submatrix caching lemma?
So now, let's analyze
matrix multiplication.
How many of you have seen
matrix multiplication before?
So a couple of you.
So here's what the
code looks like
for the standard cubic
work matrix multiplication
algorithm.
So we have two input
matrices, A and B,
And we're going to
store the result in C.
And the height and the
width of our matrix is n.
We're just going to deal
with square matrices here,
but what I'm going
to talk about also
extends to non-square matrices.
And then we just have
three loops here.
We're going to loop through i
from 0 to n minus 1, j from 0
to n minus 1, and k
from 0 to n minus 1.
And then we're going to
let's C of i n plus j
be incremented by a of i n
plus k times b of k n plus j.
So that's just the standard
code for matrix multiply.
So what's the work
of this algorithm?
It should be review
for all of you.
n cubed.
So now, let's analyze
the number of cache
misses this algorithm
is going to incur.
And again, we're going to
assume that the matrix is
in row-major order, and
we satisfy the tall cache
assumption.
We're also going to
analyze the number of cache
misses in matrix B,
because it turns out
that the number of
cache misses incurred
by matrix B is going to
dominate the number of cache
misses overall.
And there are three cases
we need to consider.
The first case is when
n is greater than c M
over B for some constant c.
And we're going to analyze
matrix B, as I said.
And we're also going to
assume LRU, because we can.
If you recall,
the LRU lemma says
that whatever we
analyze using the LRU
is just going to be a constant
factor within what we analyze
using the ideal cache.
So to do this matrix
multiplication,
I'm going to go through one
row of A and one column of B
and do the dot product there.
This is what happens
in the innermost loop.
And how many cache
misses am I going
to incur when I go down
one column of B here?
So here, I have the case where
n is greater than M over B.
So I can't fit one block
from each row into the cache.
So how many cache misses
do I have the first time
I go down a column of B?
So how many rows of B do I have?
n.
Yeah, and how many cache
misses do I need for each row?
One.
So in total, I'm going
to need n cache misses
for the first column of B.
What about the
second column of B?
So recall that I'm assuming the
LRU replacement policy here.
So when the cache
is full, I'm going
to evict the thing that
was least recently used--
used the furthest in the past.
Sorry, could you repeat that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah.
So it's still going to be n.
Why is that?
AUDIENCE: Because there
are [INAUDIBLE] integer.
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah.
It's still going
to be n, because I
can't fit one cache block
from each row into my cache.
And by the time I get back
to the top of my matrix B,
the top block has already
been evicted from the cache,
and I have to load it back in.
And this is the same for every
other block that I access.
So I'm, again, going
to need n cache misses
for the second
column of B. And this
is going to be the same
for all the columns of B.
And then I have to do this
again for the second row of A.
So in total, I'm going
to need theta of n
cubed number of cache misses.
And this is one cache miss
per entry that I access in B.
And this is not very good,
because the total work was also
theta of n cubed.
So I'm not gaining anything
from having any locality
in this algorithm here.
So any questions
on this analysis?
So this just case 1.
Let's look at case 2.
So in this case, n is
less than c M over B.
So I can fit one block from
each row of B into cache.
And then n is also greater than
another constant, c prime time
square root of M, so I can't
fit the whole matrix into cache.
And again, let's analyze
the number of cache
misses incurred by
accessing B, assuming LRU.
So how many cache
misses am I going
to incur for the
first column of B?
AUDIENCE: n.
JULIAN SHUN: n.
So that's the same as before.
What about the
second column of B?
So by the time I get to the
beginning of the matrix here,
is the top block
going to be in cache?
So who thinks the block is
still going to be in cache when
I get back to the beginning?
Yeah.
So a couple of people.
Who think it going
to be out of cache?
So it turns out it is going
to be in cache, because I
can fit one block for every
row of B into my cache
since I have n less
than c M over B.
So therefore, when I get to the
beginning of the second column,
that block is still going to be
in cache, because I loaded it
in when I was accessing
the first column.
So I'm not going to
incur any cache misses
for the second column.
And, in general, if I can fit
B columns or some constant
times B columns
into cache, then I
can reduce the number of cache
misses I have by a factor of B.
So I only need to incur a
cache miss the first time I
access of block and not for
all the subsequent accesses.
And the same is true
for the second row of A.
And since I have
m rows of A, I'm
going to have n times theta of
n squared over B cache misses.
For each row of A,
I'm going to incur
n squared over B cache misses.
So the overall number of cache
misses is n cubed over B.
And this is because
inside matrix B
I can exploit spatial locality.
Once I load in a block, I
can reuse it the next time
I traverse down a
column that's nearby.
Any questions on this analysis?
So let's look at the third case.
And here, n is less than c
prime times square root of M.
So this means that the entire
matrix fits into cache.
So let's analyze the number
of cache misses for matrix B
again, assuming LRU.
So how many cache
misses do I have now?
So let's count the
total number of cache
misses I have for every time
I go through a row of A. Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is it just n
for the first column?
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah.
So for the first column,
it's going to be n.
What about the second column?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
the second [INAUDIBLE]..
JULIAN SHUN: Right.
So basically, for
the first row of A,
the analysis is going to
be the same as before.
I need n squared over B cache
misses to load the cache in.
What about the second row of A?
How many cache misses
am I going to incur?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah.
So for the second
row of A, I'm not
going to incur any cache misses.
Because once I
load B into cache,
it's going to stay in cache.
Because the entire
matrix can fit in cache,
I assume that n is less than c
prime times square root of M.
So total number
of cache misses I
need for matrix B is theta of n
squared over B since everything
fits in cache.
And I just apply the submatrix
caching lemma from before.
Overall, this is not
a very good algorithm.
Because as you
recall, in case 1 I
needed a cubic number
of cache misses.
What happens if I swap the
order of the inner two loops?
So recall that this was one of
the optimizations in lecture 1,
when Charles was talking
about matrix multiplication
and how to speed it up.
So if I swapped the order
of the two inner loops,
then, for every
iteration, what I'm doing
is I'm actually going over
a row of C and a row of B,
and A stays fixed inside
the innermost iteration.
So now, when I analyze
the number of cache
misses of matrix
B, assuming LRU,
I'm going to benefit
from spatial locality,
since I'm going row by
row and the matrix is
stored in row-major order.
So across all of
the rows, I'm just
going to require theta of n
squared over B cache misses.
And I have to do this n
times for the outer loop.
So in total, I'm
going to get theta
of n cubed over B cache misses.
So if you swap the order
of the inner two loops
this significantly improves
the locality of your algorithm
and you can benefit
from spatial accounting.
That's why we saw a significant
performance improvement
in the first lecture when we
swapped the order of the loops.
Any questions?
So does anybody think
we can do better than n
cubed over B cache misses?
Or do you think that
it's the best you can do?
So how many people
think you can do better?
Yeah.
And how many people think
this is the best you can do?
And how many people don't care?
So it turns out
you can do better.
And we're going to
do better by using
an optimization called tiling.
So how this is going
to work is instead
of just having
three for loops, I'm
going to have six for loops.
And I'm going to
loop over tiles.
So I've got a loop over
s by s submatrices.
And within each
submatrix, I'm going
to do all of the computation
I need for that submatrix
before moving on to
the next submatrix.
So the three innermost
loops are going
to loop inside a submatrix,
and a three outermost loops
are going to loop within
the larger matrix,
one submatrix matrix at a time.
So let's analyze the
work of this algorithm.
So the work that we need to
do for a submatrix of size
s by s is going to be s cubed,
since that's just a bound
for matrix multiplication.
And then a number of times I
have to operate on submatrices
is going to be n over s cubed.
And you can see this if you just
consider each submatrix to be
a single element, and then
using the same cubic work
analysis on the smaller matrix.
So the work is n over
s cubed times s cubed,
which is equal to
theta of n cubed.
So the work of this tiled
matrix multiplies the same
as the version that
didn't do tiling.
And now, let's analyze the
number of cache misses.
So we're going to tune s so
that the submatrices just
fit into cache.
So we're going to set
s to be equal to theta
of square root of M. We
actually need to make this 1/3
square root of M,
because we need to fit
three submatrices in the cache.
But it's going to be some
constant times square
root of M.
The submatrix caching level
implies that for each submatrix
we're going to need x squared
over B misses to load it in.
And once we loaded into cache,
it fits entirely into cache,
so we can do all of our
computations within cache
and not incur any
more cache misses.
So therefore, the
total number of cache
misses we're going
to incur, it's
going to be the number
of subproblems, which
is n over s cubed and
then a number of cache
misses per subproblem,
which is s squared over B.
And if you multiply
this out, you're
going to get n cubed over
B times square root of M.
So here, I plugged in
square root of M for s.
And this is a
pretty cool result,
because it says that you
can actually do better
than the n cubed over B bound.
You can improve this bound by
a factor of square root of M.
And in practice,
square root of M
is actually not insignificant.
So, for example, if you're
looking at the last level
cache, the size of that is
on the order of megabytes.
So a square root
of M is going to be
on the order of thousands.
So this significantly
improves the performance
of the matrix
multiplication code
if you tune s so that
the submatrices just
fit in the cache.
It turns out that
this bound is optimal.
So this was shown in 1981.
So for cubic work
matrix multiplication,
this is the best you can do.
If you use another matrix
multiply algorithm,
like Strassen's algorithm,
you can do better.
So I want you to
remember this bound.
It's a very important
bound to know.
It says that for a
matrix multiplication
you can benefit both from
spatial locality as well
as temporal locality.
So I get spatial locality in
the B term in the denominator.
And then the square
root of M term
comes from temporal
locality, since I'm
doing all of the work
inside a submatrix
before I evict that
submatrix from cache.
Any questions on this analysis?
So what's one issue with
this algorithm here?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: It's not portable,
like different architecture
[INAUDIBLE].
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah.
So the problem here
is I have to tune s
for my particular machine.
And I call this a
voodoo parameter.
It's sort of like a magic
number I put into my program
so that it fits in the cache
on the particular machine I'm
running on.
And this makes the
code not portable,
because if I try to run this
code on a another machine,
the cache sizes might
be different there,
and then I won't get
the same performance
as I did on my machine.
And this is also an issue
even if you're running it
on the same machine,
because you might
have other programs
running at the same time
and using up part of the cache.
So you don't actually
know how much of the cache
your program actually gets
to use in a multiprogramming
environment.
And then this was also just
for one level of cache.
If we want to optimize
for two levels of caches,
we're going to have two
voodoo parameters, s and t.
We're going to have submatrices
and sub-submatrices.
And then we have to tune
both of these parameters
to get the best
performance on our machine.
And multi-dimensional
tuning optimization
can't be done simply
with binary search.
So if you're just tuning
for one level of cache,
you can do a binary
search on the parameter s,
but here you can't
do binary search.
So it's much more
expensive to optimize here.
And the code becomes
a little bit messier.
You have nine for
loops instead of six.
And how many levels of caches
do we have on the machines
that we're using today?
AUDIENCE: Three.
JULIAN SHUN: Three.
So for three level cache, you
have three voodoo parameters.
You have 12 nested for loops.
This code becomes very ugly.
And you have to tune
these parameters
for your particular machine.
And this makes the
code not very portable,
as one student pointed out.
And in a multiprogramming
environment,
you don't actually know
the effective cache size
that your program has access to.
Because other jobs are running
at the same time, and therefore
it's very easy to
mistune the parameters.
Was their question?
No?
So any questions?
Yeah.
Is there a way to
programmatically get
the size of the cache?
[INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah.
So you can auto-tune
your program
so that it's optimized
for the cache sizes
of your particular machine.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
instruction
to get the size of
the cache [INAUDIBLE]..
JULIAN SHUN: Instruction to
get the size of your cache.
I'm not actually sure.
Do you know?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] in--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Yeah, in the proc--
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah, proc cpuinfo.
AUDIENCE: Yeah. proc cpuinfo
or something like that.
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah.
So you can probably
get that as well.
AUDIENCE: And I
think if you google,
I think you'll find
it pretty quickly.
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
But even if you do
that, and you're
running this program when
other jobs are running,
you don't actually know how much
cache your program has access
to.
Yes?
Is cache of architecture
and stuff like that
optimized around
matrix problems?
JULIAN SHUN: No.
They're actually
general purpose.
Today, we're just looking
at matrix multiply,
but on Thursday's
lecture we'll actually
be looking at many
other problems
and how to optimize them
for the cache hierarchy.
Other questions?
So this was a good algorithm
in terms of cache performance,
but it wasn't very portable.
So let's see if
we can do better.
Let's see if we can come
up with a simpler design
where we still get pretty
good cache performance.
So we're going to turn
to divide and conquer.
We're going to look at the
recursive matrix multiplication
algorithm that we saw before.
Again, we're going to
deal with square matrices,
but the results generalize
to non-square matrices.
So how this works is
we're going to split
our [INAUDIBLE] matrices
into four submatrices or four
quadrants.
And then for each quadrant
of the output matrix,
it's just going to be the sum
of two matrix multiplies on n
over 2 by n over 2 matrices.
So c 1 1 one is going
to be a 1 1 times b 1 1,
plus a 1 2 times B 2 1.
And then we're going
to do this recursively.
So every level of
recursion we're
going to get eight
multiplied adds of n over 2
by n over 2 matrices.
Here's what the recursive
code looks like.
You can see that we have
eight recursive calls here.
The base case here is of size 1.
In practice, you want to coarsen
the base case to overcome
function call overheads.
Let's also look at what these
values here correspond to.
So I've color coded these
so that they correspond
to particular elements
in the submatrix
that I'm looking
at on the right.
So these values here
correspond to the index
of the first element in
each of my quadrants.
So the first element
in my first quadrant
is just going to
have an offset of 0.
And then the first element
of my second quadrant,
that's going to
be on the same row
as the first element
in my first quadrant.
So I just need to add the
width of my quadrant, which
is n over 2.
And then to get the first
element in quadrant 2 1,
I'm going to jump over
and over two rows.
And each row has
a length row size,
so it's just going to be
n over 2 times row size.
And then to get the first
element in quadrant 2 2,
it's just the first element
in quadrant 2 1 plus n over 2.
So that's n over 2
times row size plus 1.
So let's analyze the
work of this algorithm.
So what's the recurrence
for this algorithm--
for the work of this algorithm?
So how many
subproblems do we have?
AUDIENCE: Eight
JULIAN SHUN: Eight.
And what's the size of
each Subproblem n over 2.
And how much work are we doing
to set up the recursive calls?
A constant amount of work.
So the recurrences is
W of n is equal to 8 W
n over 2 plus theta of 1.
And what does that solve to?
n cubed.
So it's one of the three
cases of the master theorem.
We're actually going to
analyze this in more detail
by drawing out the
recursion tree.
And this is going to give
us more intuition about why
the master theorem is true.
So at the top level
of my recursion tree,
I'm going to have a
problem of size n.
And then I'm going to branch
into eight subproblems of size
n over 2.
And then I'm going to do
a constant amount of work
to set up the recursive calls.
Here, I'm just
labeling this with one.
So I'm ignoring the constants.
But it's not going to matter
for asymptotic analysis.
And then I'm going
to branch again
into eight subproblems
of size n over 4.
And eventually, I'm going
to get down to the leaves.
And how many levels do I have
until I get to the leaves?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Log n.
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah.
So log n-- what's
the base of the log?
Yeah.
So it's log base 2 of n,
because I'm dividing my problem
size by 2 every time.
And therefore, the
number of leaves
I have is going to be 8
to the log base 2 of n,
because I'm branching it
eight ways every time.
8 to the log base 2 of n is
the same as n to the log base
2 of 8, which is n cubed.
The amount of work I'm doing
at the top level is constant.
So I'm just going to say 1 here.
At the next level, it's
eight times, then 64.
And then when I
get to the leaves,
it's going to be
theta of n cubed,
since I have m cubed
leaves, and they're all
doing constant work.
And the work is geometrically
increasing as I go down
the recursion tree.
So the overall work is
just dominated by the work
I need to do at the leaves.
So the overall work is just
going to be theta of n cubed.
And this is the
same as the looping
versions of matrix multiply--
they're all cubic work.
Now, let's analyze the number
of cache misses of this divide
and conquer algorithm.
So now, my recurrence is
going to be different.
My base case now is when the
submatrix fits in the cache--
so when n squared is less than
c M. And when that's true,
I just need to load that
submatrix into cache,
and then I don't incur
any more cache misses.
So I need theta of n
squared over B cache
misses when n squared is less
than c M for some sufficiently
small constant c, less
than or equal to 1.
And then, otherwise, I recurse
into 8 subproblems of size n
over 2.
And then I add theta
of 1, because I'm
doing a constant amount of work
to set up the recursive calls.
And I get this state of
n squared over B term
from the submatrix
caching lemma.
It says I can just load the
entire matrix into cache
with this many cache misses.
So the difference between
the cache analysis here
and the work analysis before
is that I have a different base
case.
And I think in all
of the algorithms
that you've seen before,
the base case was always
of a constant size.
But here, we're working
with a base case
that's not of a constant size.
So let's try to analyze this
using the recursion tree
approach.
So at the top level, I
have a problem of size n
that I'm going to branch
into eight problems of size n
over 2.
And then I'm also going to
incur a constant number of cache
misses.
I'm just going to say 1 here.
Then I'm going to branch again.
And then, eventually, I'm
going to get to the base case
where n squared
is less than c M.
And when n squared is less than
c M, then the number of cache
misses that I'm going
to incur is going
to be theta of c M over B. So
I can just plug-in c M here
for n squared.
And the number of
levels of recursion
I have in this recursion tree is
no longer just log base 2 of n.
I'm going to have log base
2 of n minus log base 2
of square root of c M
number of levels, which
is the same as log base
2 of n minus 1/2 times
log base 2 of c M. And then,
the number of leaves I get
is going to be 8 to this
number of levels here.
So it's 8 to log base 2 of n
minus 1/2 of log base 2 of c M.
And this is equal to the theta
of n cubed over M to the 3/2.
So the n cubed comes from the
8 to the log base 2 of n term.
And then if I do 8 to the
negative 1/2 of log base 2
of c M, that's just going
to give me M to the 3/2
in the denominator.
So any questions on how I
computed the number of levels
of this recursion tree here?
So I'm basically dividing
my problem size by 2
until I get to a problem
size that fits in the cache.
So that means n is less
than square root of c M.
So therefore, I can
subtract that many levels
for my recursion tree.
And then to get the
number of leaves,
since I'm branching
eight ways, I
just do 8 to the power of
the number of levels I have.
And then that gives me the
total number of leaves.
So now, let's analyze
a number of cache
misses I need each level
of this recursion tree.
At the top level, I
have a constant number
of cache misses--
let's just say 1.
The next level, I have 8, 64.
And then at the
leaves, I'm going
to have theta of n cubed over
B times square root of M cache
misses.
And I got this quantity
just by multiplying
the number of
leaves by the number
of cache misses per leaf.
So number of leaves is n
cubed over M to the 3/2.
The cache misses per leaves
is theta of c M over B.
So I lose one factor of
B in the denominator.
I'm left with the square
root of M at the bottom.
And then I also divide
by the block size B.
So overall, I get n cubed over
B times square root of M cache
misses.
And again, this is
a geometric series.
And the number of cache
misses at the leaves
dominates all of
the other levels.
So the total number
of cache misses
I have is going to
be theta of n cubed
over B times square root of M.
And notice that I'm getting
the same number of cache
misses as I did with the
tiling version of the code.
But here, I don't actually
have the tune my code
for the particular cache size.
So what cache sizes
does this code work for?
So is this code going
to work on your machine?
Is it going to get
good cache performance?
So this code is going to
work for all cache sizes,
because I didn't tune it for
any particular cache size.
And this is what's known as
a cache-oblivious algorithm.
It doesn't have any
voodoo tuning parameters,
it has no explicit
knowledge of the caches,
and it's essentially
passively auto-tuning itself
for the particular cache
size of your machine.
It can also work for
multi-level caches
automatically, because I never
specified what level of cache
I'm analyzing this for.
I can analyze it for
any level of cache,
and it's still going to give
me good cache complexity.
And this is also good in
multiprogramming environments,
where you might have
other jobs running
and you don't know your
effective cache size.
This is just going to passively
auto-tune for whatever
cache size is available.
It turns out that the best
cache-oblivious codes to date
work on arbitrary
rectangular matrices.
I just talked about
square matrices,
but the best codes work
on rectangular matrices.
And they perform
binary splitting
instead of eight-way splitting.
And you're split on the
largest of i, j, and k.
So this is what the best
cache-oblivious matrix
multiplication algorithm does.
Any questions?
So I only talked about
the serial setting so far.
I was assuming that
these algorithms
ran on just a single thread.
What happens if I go
to multiple processors?
It turns out that the
results do generalize
to a parallel context.
So this is the recursive
parallel matrix multiply
code that we saw before.
And notice that we're executing
four sub calls in parallel,
doing a sync, and then
doing four more sub
calls in parallel.
So let's try to analyze
the number of cache
misses in this parallel code.
And to do that, we're going
to use this theorem, which
says that let Q sub p
be the number of cache
misses in a deterministic
cell computation
why run on P processors, each
with a private cache of size M.
And let S sub p be the
number of successful steals
during the computation.
In the ideal cache model,
the number of cache
misses we're going to have
is Q sub p equal to Q sub 1
plus big O of number of
steals times M over B.
So the number of cache misses
in the parallel context is
equal to the number of cache
misses when you run it serially
plus this term here, which
is the number of steals
times M over B.
And the proof for this goes
as follows-- so every call
in the Cilk runtime
system, we can
have workers steal
tasks from other workers
when they don't have work to do.
And after a worker steals
a task from another worker,
it's cache becomes completely
cold in the worst case,
because it wasn't actually
working on that subproblem
before.
But after M over B
cold cache misses,
its cache is going to become
identical to what it would
be in the serial execution.
So we just need to
pay M over B cache
misses to make it so that
the cache looks the same as
if it were executing serially.
And the same is
true when a worker
resumes a stolen subcomputation
after a Cilk sync.
And the number of times that
these two situations can happen
is 2 times as S p--
2 times the number of steals.
And each time, we have to
pay M over b cache misses.
And this is where this additive
term comes from-- order
S sub p times M over B.
We also know that the number
of steals in a Cilk program
is upper-bounded by
P times T infinity,
in the expectation where P
is the number of processors
and T infinity is the
span of your computation.
So if you can minimize the
span of your computation,
then this also gives
you a good cache bounds.
So moral of the story
here is that minimizing
the number of cache
misses in a serial elision
essentially minimizes them
in the parallel execution
for a low span algorithm.
So in this recursive matrix
multiplication algorithm,
the span of this is as follows--
so T infinity of n is 2T
infinity of of n over 2
plus theta of 1.
Since we're doing
a sync here, we
have to pay the critical
path length of two sub calls.
This solves to theta of n.
And applying to previous
lemma, this gives us
a cache miss bound of theta of
n cubed over B square root of M.
This is just the same
as the serial execution
And then this additive term is
going to be order P times n.
And it's a span times M over B
So that was a parallel
algorithm for matrix multiply.
And we saw that we can also
get good cache bounds there.
So here's a summary of
what we talked about today.
We talked about associativity
and caches, different ways
you can design a cache.
We talked about the
ideal cache model
that's useful for
analyzing algorithms.
We talked about
cache-aware algorithms
that have explicit
knowledge of the cache.
And the example we used
was titled matrix multiply.
Then we came up with a
much simpler algorithm
that was cache-oblivious
using divide and conquer.
And then on Thursday's
lecture, we'll
actually see much more on
cache-oblivious algorithm
design.
And then you'll also
have an opportunity
to analyze the cache
efficiency of some algorithms
in the next homework.